point grap un histoirag cher à la
raconté Axel gvin l'a ramassé l'a écrit
le ban dessin c'est williamsit et le
livre là les fait par les éditions
tikouti navit un foie pour un bonne fois
Monsieur le foi la Manche son fois qu'un
grain de selle un jour le roi la tombe
malade après ça la guéri seulement
longtemps l'ILA reste faible le cor tu
es en flemme la bouche tu es mauvais
toute ça que donne à pour manger l' veut
pas l' en foule ce som le plus gadiom
bouillon volail il fait faet à la bouche
de l'eau Liv pas même à
forant mange pas l'
fin comarête l'amouru
ou il demande si son ti F est tracassé
il
plaî pleur en
joiné partout il fa d' affair le roi les
RISC manger un affire pour fait la
bouche son papa tamarin ver ù citron
Galé
bilinbi le roi
en il mange pas même qu son papa es là
la princesse fait semble
R pour
encourager mais dès que son papa il voit
pas elle gros PL r des vides par le
jolis yeux le joli
timanzel un jour c'est pas quoi ça
l'arrivé le roi dit son fi h
SP des trit les arrangement
bouche la princesse il saute en l'air
contentement mais seulement tout de
suite son cœur y sert
aller trouf les en plein Milie mois de
septembre h
elle y abandonne pas seulement elle y
appelle son garde champette en vitesse
je vous donne l'ordre d'aller partout
bat en bois crie la fille du roi se mari
avec le Bou porte pour son papa
manger dessus ch va c'est lesbdé garde
champette il passe partout dans la ville
dans petit village dans le coin dans le
recoin dans la forêt dans la savane
partout partout il battent Enour partout
il fanent la
nouvelle un jour un bonjour nouvelle là
il tombe dans oreilles monsieur cascoco
boire de l'eau monsieur là avait trois
pied de si ch pied les Ch Lavit un grap
les bien M ilvit aussi trois garçons
premier garçon il appelle le blanc
pasitô il apprend la nouvelle monsieur
cass coco bois de l'eau il fait appel le
blanc mon garçon mon grand garçon allez
en vitesse fais au toilette met tout
costume Gal tout un petit goutte
brillantine d' chevux fais le vif à la
le blanc parti avec le plus joli grap de
Chi pour
lu gagne en mariage la fit le roi le
blanc il marche content le blanc à part
cl qui se est capable trouve les en
plein milieu mois de septembre le blanc
il SIIF il
chante tout d'un coup après un contour
chemin un VI F assis si un Galé le vie F
l' fatigué les fatigué même gros
transpiration il coule dans le coup le
blanc il passe r devant il fait semblant
il voit pas il il a point le temps s
sal monieur petit
monsieur tu monsieur onurait point bon c
moi un peu
porte mon paquet de bois les pas si
tellement lour mais seulement les lours
à point VI forme comme moi
B don la
viille là
mieur messieur mal bien soif don
béatella n'aurait point à faire pour
rafraîchir la bouche nal dedans
cou le blanc ça va en chalè àause FEM la
retard la retard son marage sur tout AC
la fille le roi
ainsi tellement jolie fille il dit la
gagne
50 kg de mon en mariage le blanc il
arrive devant le roi avec son béatel
l'IR des GC lezel là le petit princesse
décharge le béatel aïe Aï a a a a rien
Galé dans son béatel garde sans pête
souz-moi ce
malfondé dès que le blanc fin arriver
dès que la fine raconte son mie bien sûr
il a pas raconté histoires le vie FEM le
bon cheminin monsieur casass coco boire
de l'eau il fait Rore son deuxième
garçon appelle le gris
mon noir allez vitement met tout l'ING
nilon dégagé à là le gris parti avec le
deème grap les moins rose que le premier
mais tant pis le gris il trac
send monsieur soupl le vie F toujours à
la même sur le bon chemin pouville le
gris mieur on naurit pointtit quelque
chose de béatel pour arrange mon vieille
bouche dans mon béatel nana crapau la
vieille ou il vait un crapau pour
arangeou de
bouche tellement le gris la pourri son
machoir il manque des crochets mais
seulement l'Î à Paris quand carapau la
sorte P vraiment dans son Bertel la S en
l'air la commence crier devant le roi il
la Paris dit tout quand la trape ài la M
ài la Jo criqué c ça répondre
craquer fin ti son quinjo laazol le gris
retourne son
cas il raconte pas le M son papa
toujours histoire vie FME c'est le bon
cheminin vie gramoun casse coco boire de
l'eau il plaît à dans son dépitation mon
espoir les mort jamais jamais mi tombera
en parmi famille le roi jamais jamais
crie un coup quand même le noir pour
moins va le noir troè garçon il débarque
son linge l'écrasé n'a point soulier sa
VAT jusqu'à l point mon pauvre garçon
allez dégom un peu mais tout blé de Chau
l'écraser rien n'a point le temps fait
Chau carreau
tachmanier pas bouton PAL en RCL c'estàd
premier bouton s dernier trou hein mais
tout vie soulier commignon sous de pied
as le toil noir pour lesip pour le roi
pasôt
Bali le noir l'attrape souer et la
mettre de côté la vieille là les la même
mon noir
onurit pas
uneire dans béatel pour la mertume dans
mon bouche tout suite le noir il cass
àelle grandmère Mo un petit bouquetch
dedans seulement sal chez le grain gû si
on trouve bon mange allz la diamte ça
pour le fit le roi seulement mon cœ fait
mal comme ça sur le bon chemin mange
tout si ve non mon garçon il est trop
gentil
mê porte les autes pour princesse allez
B a
là-bas le noir arrive devant le roi
plonge la main dans son béatel
les
les maman belle rose comme cardinal gros
épaulle tigrin rien
philippine le roi C vol de Sissa pareil
un
goulipia la princesse embrasse le noir
si tant tell tellement elle est content
papa je vous présente mon
fiancé criquz ça répond
craquer ces histoir là s' estement TER
les pas moin le TER mais raconte àot ça
pour faire rire la bouche et puazot
comme ça il vaut mieux rendre
service un vie gramoun plutôt faire le
magistrat l' l'ANT l'
l'intéressant